valentina buenas tardes de sala abdeslam
parece decidido a hablar llevamos un
poco más de una hora de audiencia y ya
tuvo que ser suspendida por los dichos
del único sobreviviente de los comandos
del 13 de noviembre que toma la palabra
sin la autorización del presidente de la
corte ayer recordemos lo hizo varias
veces en una de ellas se reconoció como
un combatiente del grupo estado islámico
lo que afectó sobre todo a las víctimas
civiles presentes les propongo que
escuchemos algunos algunas víctimas del
ataque
ya no fue una reacción de sorpresa es
exactamente lo que él hizo en bruselas
lo que es un poco inesperado es que en
lugar de ceñirse a su lógica y dejar de
hablar respondió la mitad de las
preguntas sobre su dirección etcétera
creemos que hay poca inteligencia detrás
de su comportamiento algo compacto
esta persona que está en el banquillo y
del que no diré ni el nombre ni el
apellido porque no quiero convertirlo en
el protagonista de esta historia para mí
y para mi asociación es un asesino
así que es una provocación lo
esperábamos y estábamos preparados para
ello y de hecho no esperamos nada de él
erika que se espera para hoy se retomará
la audiencia en qué momento que nuevos
detalles hay
la audiencia ya ha sido retomada
valentina había una discusión muy
técnica entre el presidente y los
abogados cuando sala de slam tomó la
palabra él dijo que en molenbeek su
barrio de bruselas conocido por el
salafismo de los jóvenes había muchas
víctimas también preguntó cuando se le
va a dar la voz a las víctimas de siria
y luego hizo una frase muy técnica dijo
la sabiduría creer que a un hombre se ha
condenado luego de ser juzgado nosotros
tenemos la presunción de inocencia
aunque no creamos en vuestra justicia
sino hoy continúa la lista no cierto de
las partes civiles es algo muy lento son
más de 1800 partes civiles esa tarea va
a durar hasta mañana vamos a ver si
nuevamente sala abdeslam toma la palabra